und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka guten
abend der ball rollt weiter durch volle
stadien und wie geht es weiter mit
corona das rk ii meldet heute eine 7
tage incidents von 5 das ist zwar immer
noch schön niedrig aber auf den zweiten
blick nicht mehr ganz so schön die
inzidenz sinkt nämlich nicht mehr
doch was das konkret bedeutet ist im
moment noch schwer zu prognostizieren
werden wegen delta die zahlen auch bei
uns schon bald wieder steigen und mit
welchen folgen
schließlich schreibt mir auch die
impfungen voran zu diesen und anderen
fragen gleich ein expertengespräch doch
zunächst ein kurzer aktueller bericht
von domenic löschmeister als gäbe es
kein corona keine hochansteckende delta
variante englische fußballfans gestern
abend in london
delta breitet sich rasant in
großbritannien aus doch die regierung
hält dann lockerungen fest sogar eine
aufhebung der masken pflicht ist im
gespräch
wir alle sollten zwar darauf vorbereitet
sein dass die fälle weiter zunehmen
werden aber wir müssen jetzt in eine
andere zeit eintreten in der wir lernen
mit dem virus zu leben
corona kommt zurück in europa zypern ist
mit einer 7 tage incidence von 287
spitzenreiter großbritannien dahinter
mit 243 portugal meldet 136 und spanien
109 fälle pro 100.000 einwohner
innerhalb von sieben tagen im
urlaubsland spanien droht eine neue
welle hunderte junge leute steckten sich
bei abi fahrten auf mallorca mit dem
virus an
in barcelona verdreifachten sich die
korona zahlen in nur einer woche
katalonien ist wieder risikogebiet mit
den urlaubern wird die delta variante
immer mehr auch nach deutschland kommen
delta wird auch bald in deutschland die
dominierende variante sein
ich gehe davon aus dass wir noch im juli
sehen werden das gelte auch bei uns über
70 80 prozent der infektionen ausmacht
doch strengere regeln für
reiserückkehrer sie
soll es vorerst nicht geben dabei ist
die sorge groß dass mit dem
familienurlaub die korona zahlen vor
allem in den schulen steigen werden denn
nur wenige kinder und jugendliche sind
aktuell geimpft und in großbritannien
hier stehen kommende woche die beiden
halbfinalspiele sowie das finale der em
an mit 60.000 fußballfans im wembley
stadion und in berlin spreche ich mit
professor leif erik santer er leitet die
impfstoffforschung an der berliner
charité guten abend herr professor
sander und slomka
wenn sie diese bilder sehen von
proppenvollen fußball-stadien wie wirkt
das auf sie da ist hier das schon auch
mit einer gewissen sorge ich verstehe
dass auf der einen seite das schöne ist
dass jetzt fußball wieder los geht und
dass das auch andere dinge als corona
gibt aber wir sind schon noch in einer
übergangsphase in dieser pandemie und
wir sollten jetzt auch nicht zu
leichtsinnig werden und sehr sehr viele
menschenansammlungen und sehr viele
menschen auf einem haufen gibt halt
immer noch die gefahr einer virus
übertragung gerade jetzt mit der neuen
delta variante in einigen ländern
steigen ja jetzt die zahlen auch wieder
auch ganz ordentlich wie sehr besorgt
sie dass das delta dazu einer neuen ja
an der neuen pandemischen situation
führen könnte
das ist natürlich schon ungünstig dass
jetzt wieder an der virusvariante haben
die noch mal ansteckender ist die auch
so eine gewisse flucht mutationen sich
trägt also die impfstoffe ganz bisschen
schlechter wirken nicht die wirkung
verlieren aber ein ganz bisschen
schlechter wirken
das heißt es noch mal eine neue
herausforderung also zunächst gegen die
zahlen schön runter durch den imf effekt
durch die ganzen effekte der maßnahmen
die ergriffen wurden
und jetzt sieht man einfach mit dieser
variante steigt es darunter wieder
deswegen ist das natürlich schon
gewissermaßen besorgniserregend auf der
anderen seite müssen wir eben auch ganz
genau beobachten inwiefern dann
überhaupt beispielsweise auch die
krankenhauseinweisungen steigen und die
krankheits und todesfälle steigen wir
hoffen da auf eine gewisse entkopplung
das eben durch die hohe impfrate viele
der menschen die sehr empfänglich waren
für kroner virusinfektionen schon
gewissen schutz haben
aber werden immunität dieses oft
verwendete wort das soll ja auch bei
dieser variante noch einmal deutlich
schwieriger werden zumal ja auch kinder
und jugendliche zum beispiel eben noch
nicht geimpft werden oder wenig ja ganz
genau so ist es dadurch dass die sich
nochmals stärker überträgt wäre dann die
zahl derer die man impfen müsste in der
bevölkerung noch höher
um auch diesen herdenschutz zu erreichen
diese effekte haben wir ja schon gesehen
zum beispiel in england und in israel
und auch bei uns haben wir das gesehen
in den krankenhauseinweisungen und in
den schweren krankheitsfällen und
todesfällen dass die impfung schon einen
effekt hat
aber um wirklich an der herdenimmunität
zu erreichen müsste man mit so einer
ansteckenden virus variante noch einmal
mehr menschen
dann werden natürlich eltern
verständlicherweise nicht die neigung
haben zu sagen ich impfe mein kind für
die nation chancen für die
gesamtgesellschaft wenn alle eltern
fragen sich ist das gut für mein kind
wie handhaben sie das werden sie ihre
kinder impfen jetzt erstmal so dass wir
im stoff haben die zugelassen sind ab 12
jahren und die studien laufen weiters
wird auch eine zulassung dann für
jüngere kinder geben wenn die
studienergebnisse da sind und in den
studie hat sich gezeigt dass die eben
von hervorragend wirkt und bislang das
sind daten von der amerikanischen
behörde cdc sieht das sicherheitsprofil
auch sehr gut aus natürlich ist die
kosten nutzen rechnung bei kindern eine
andere die erkrankung hat wesentlich
seltener schwer an corona virus
nichtsdestotrotz muss man sagen wenn das
vollkommen ungebremst durch die ganzen
kinder und jugendlichen durch rauschen
würde dann würden wir auch dort schwere
krankheitsfälle sehen ich ganz
persönlich würde meine kinder
beispielsweise auch impfen lassen
dann gibt es noch ein anderes thema zu
dem sie uns als im fond impfstoff
forscher um etwas sagen können stichwort
astra das kam für viele dann recht
überraschend als die stiko plötzlich
sagte auch besser als nur zweiter
achtung jetzt direkt eine biotech
impfung das kommt für manche auch zu
spät die jetzt erst gerade erst
womöglich ihre zweite astra impfung
bekommen haben wann können die denn dann
auch einen mr einer impfstoff bekommen
muss man da jetzt lange warten oder was
was fragen sie zunächst einmal muss man
sagen dass auch die menschen die zwei
mal mit astrazeneca geimpft worden sind
sehr guten schutz auch gegen die delta
variante haben da sieht man
glücklicherweise schon in großbritannien
wo ja schon sehr viel von der delta
variante zirkuliert und auch diese
menschen sind geschützt beispielsweise
von schweren krankheitsverlauf und im
verlauf wird man ohnehin diskutieren
dass man ältere menschen menschen mit
einem schwächeren immunsystem im herbst
schon wieder auffrischt und ich glaube
eine dritte impfung dann auch für
doppelt astra geimpfte wäre dann eine
möglichkeit und da sehe ich eigentlich
hier kein problem das auch märz zu
machen muss man sich da keine sorgen
machen dass man dann zu viel impfstoff
im körper hat das ist eine immunantwort
die richtet sich gegen ein bestimmtes
antigenen wir dass eine bestimmte stelle
im virus und auch das immunsystem hat
einen gewissen sättigung bereich und
dass man jetzt zu viel davon bekommt das
ist im grunde genommen nicht möglich
herr professor sander danke
pressegespräch das virus zu bekämpfen
ist das eine
da hat die forschung gewaltige
fortschritte gemacht doch wie dieses
virus überhaupt auf den menschen sprang
das ist noch nicht geklärt wo lag der
ursprung dieser pandemie die nicht nur
von der deutschen kanzlerin schon als
jahrhundertereignis bezeichnet wird
bei der letzten jahrhundert solche der
spanischen grippe wird an dieser frage
bis heute geforscht
trotz des namens war spanien wo nicht
der ursprungsort als aktuellste
wissenschaftlich anerkannte these gilt
dass sich ein menschliches virus mit
einem vogelgrippevirus kreuzte und das
mutmaßlichen amerika und von dort dann
ausbreitet
damals in der endphase des ersten
weltkriegs gab es anfangs aber auch
vermutung die deutsche wehrmacht habe
mikroben gezüchtet um sie als waffe
einzusetzen dass eine pandemie
spekulationen auslöst ist also kein
neues phänomen
welche thesen ist so saß koch 2 gibt
berichtet benjamin daniel
es ist nur etwa 1 100 tausendstel
zentimeter groß und doch schaffte es das
virus saß kopf zwei die ganze welt aus
den angeln zu heben
menschenleere großstadt straßen
sterbender einzelhandel social distance
nehmen sie es auch das wird ein düsterer
winter eingangs dunkler dieses virus ist
sehr schlau und tötet gerne die schwach
wie es das virus entstanden wo kam es
her
zwei große fragen die auch vincent rack
aniello umtreiben er ist einer der
führenden virologen amerikas es begann
als politischer kampf trump beute china
für alles verantwortlich machen das
glaubten ihm viele leute bis heute als
belastet unsere beziehungen zu china
dabei müssen wir enger zusammenarbeiten
um die ursachen zu erforschen
ende mai hat joe biden seine
geheimdienste gebeten dem ursprung des
corona virus auf den grund zu gehen
der bericht soll in den nächsten monaten
erscheinen bis jetzt werden vor allem
zwei theorien diskutiert nummer eins das
virus ist auf natürlichem wege
entstanden die vermutung es ist von
fledermäusen über ein anderes tier auf
einem fleischmarkt ingo hahn auf den
menschen übergesprungen
das hält die weltgesundheitsorganisation
für wahrscheinlich allerdings behindert
china deren untersuchungen stellt
unzureichende datensätze bereit
das virus das in fan zum ersten mal
entdeckt wurde ist den sehr ähnlich dass
man 2013 bei einer fledermaus gefunden
hat etwa 1000 kilometer von johann
entfernt es ist also wahrscheinlich dass
auch satz zwei das jetzt millionen
menschen infizierte von einer fledermaus
stammt
[Musik]
eine weitere theorie das virus ist in
diesem forschungslabor in wuchern
entstanden und durch einen unfall
freigesetzt wurden
das behauptete damals trumps
außenminister mike kompon manche stellen
gar die these in den raum china habe an
einer biologischen waffe geforscht
beweise für all das gibt es nicht
es gibt keinerlei daten die diese
theorie untermauern kein labor der welt
hat vor dezember 2009 10 mit etwas
vergleichbaren zu saas kopf zwei
hantiert es gibt also keine möglichkeit
dass es irgendwo aus dringen konto es
hat nicht existiert
vor wenigen tagen dann dieser new york
times artikel
demnach seien rund 200 datensätze von
saas kopf zwei proben aus pan aus einer
internationalen datenbank gelöscht
worden
ein forscher habe sie aus einer cloud
wieder hergestellt diese gen sequenzen
früherer corona fälle kann man sich
online ansehen sie offenbaren ehrlich
gesagt nichts überraschendes
meiner meinung nach wurde hier viel lärm
gemacht um zu behaupten der china hier
etwas verstecken wollte das scheint aber
nicht der fall zu sein
das virus seine verbreitung sein
ursprung die suche nach antworten geht
weiter und wird vielleicht nie enden
hilfreich wäre jedenfalls wenn china bei
diesen fragen offen agieren würde
viele weitere hintergründe zum thema
corona finden sie auf zdf heute.de etwa
zu der frage wie sich die delta variante
weiter auswirken kann
sommerzeit das ist auch die zeit der
sommerinterviews längere ausgeruhte
gespräche abseits der politischen
alltagshektik aber natürlich trotzdem zu
aktuellen themen die sommerinterviews
gibt es seit den 80er jahren als
zdf-journalisten anfingen den
spitzenpolitikern in ihrer sommerferien
hinterher zu reisen heute reiste theo
koll auf den brocken bei ordentlich wind
traf er dort auf bundespräsident frank
walter steinmeier der gerade erst seinen
hut in den ring geworfen hat für eine
zweite amtszeit
ob er wieder gewählt wird ist aber
keineswegs sicher christian hübscher hat
für uns das interview zusammengefasst
weil ich der bundespräsident auf dem
gipfel des brocken an rollt ist er
gerade durch eine völlig zerstörte
landschaft gefahren der wald im harz
stirbt vor aller augen seit jahren schon
grotesk perfekte kulisse für steinmeiers
meinung der brocken zeigt uns warum
effektive klimaschutzpolitik notwendig
ist viele abgestorbene bäume die folgen
von erderwärmung
klimawandel und borkenkäfer sind hier
gut zu sehen und auch was zu tun ist
steinmeier wird hier oben heute nicht
nur ein zdf sommerinterview geben
sondern auch wandern gehen mit bürgern
aus ost und west harz die beiden
ministerpräsidenten der grenzregion
haben sich dran gehängt
auf der suche nach dem direkten kontakt
zum volk den es während der pandemie
zwangsläufig nicht gab
wie hat sich das in den letzten zehn
fünfzehn sechzehn monaten hier
entwickelt was dürftig was drin war es
einsam gestand mayer hat dann gefragt ob
ihr unterstützung bekommen haben krone
helfen bekommen haben waren nur sehr
marginal
aber wir sind trotzdem da durchgekommen
und wir gucken optimistisch nach vorne
das fand ja auch glaube ich ganz gut
es ist derselbe bundespräsident der alle
einschneidenden krisen maßnahmen der
regierung mitgetragen hat und auch die
bundes notbremse unterschrieb ohne zu
zögern ein politikversagen sieht er
nicht den laufenden wahlkampf aber
beobachtet er kritisch ich habe sorge
dass es eine schlammschlacht werden
könnte die wahlkämpfenden parteien sind
immer wieder daran zu erinnern gerade in
der deutschen demokratie die wegen des
wahlsystems auf koalitionen angewiesen
muss man bei jedem wort bei jedem satz
daran denken dass man möglicherweise
hinterher wieder gemeinsam am tisch
sitzen muss steinmeier überraschte im
mai als er sich selbst für eine zweite
amtszeit vorschlug ohne gefragt worden
zu sein ohne zu wissen ob er mit einer
neuen regierung überhaupt noch
mehrheiten haben wird die meisten die
heute hier mit ihm wandern finden das
gut
nur herr bartsch der museumsleiter
spricht aus was steinmeier auch
gefährlich werden könnte wenn ich ganz
ehrlich bin wünsche ich mir gern mal
eine frau an der spitze dieses landes
und deswegen hoffe ich dass es geeignete
kandidatinnen und andere
persönlichkeiten gibt von steinmeier hat
die frage erwartet müsste erst mich eine
frau sein
und da kann ich auch nur sagen ich kann
nur als der kandidieren der ich bin ich
bringe das mit was man von mir kennt und
das wird entweder wertgeschätzt oder
nicht wertgeschätzt ein bundespräsident
der nochmal will auch wenn ihn bisher
niemand gerufen hat erst im februar
lange nach der bundestagswahl wird klar
sein ob es für ihn weitergeht und jetzt
erstmal heinz geholfen den nachrichten
beim absturz eines militärflugzeugs auf
den philippinen sind 45 menschen ums
leben gekommen
42 insassen der maschine und drei
menschen am boden
in dem flugzeug waren 96 soldaten fast
50 konnten zum teil schwer verletzt
den trümmern gerettet werden mehrere
insassen werden noch vermisst
das flugzeug sollte die soldaten zu
einem einsatz auf der insel jolo bringen
zehn tage nach dem teileinsturz eines
wohnkomplexes in miami ist die suche
nach opfern und verschütteten bewohnern
vorübergehend eingestellt worden
die gebäudereste sollen jetzt
schnellstmöglich abgerissen werden
morgen werden die ausläufer eines
tropensturms in florida erwartet der die
ruine unkontrolliert zum einsturz
bringen könnte
24 opfer wurde bislang tot geborgen 121
menschen werden noch vermisst
nach dem abgang einer schlammlawine in
der japanischen küstenstadt atami suchen
rettungskräfte weiter nach etwa 20
vermissten
dabei muss der einsatz immer wieder
unterbrochen werden wegen anhaltender
regenfälle besteht die gefahr weiterer
erdrutsche
die lawine war wie eine flutwelle am
samstagvormittag durch den kurort
gerollt 130 häuser wurden zerstört oder
beschädigt mindestens zwei menschen
kamen ums leben
nach einem massiven hacker-angriff auf
unternehmen in mehreren ländern ist das
genaue ausmaß nach wie vor nicht
abzuschätzen
in deutschland meldete sich beim
bundesamt für sicherheit in der
informationstechnik ein it dienstleister
dessen kunden betroffen sein
es handle sich um einige tausend
computer bei mehreren unternehmen
us-präsident beiden ordnete eine
untersuchung des angriffs durch die
geheimdienste an
während einer rundreise im us staat
michigan sagte er auf fragen von
reportern
der erste eindruck sei gewesen dass
nicht die russische regierung dahinter
stecke aber man sei sich noch nicht
sicher
das hacken ist ja nur eine form
sogenannter cyber attacken eine andere
besteht darin digitale technologien für
gezielte desinformations kampagnen zu
nutzen
vor allem soziale medien sind hier ein
beliebtes einfallstor
das scheint den bundesbürgern inzwischen
auch durchaus bewusst
in einer aktuellen repräsentativen
studie des meinungsforschungsinstituts
politik sagen 85 prozent dass sie
falschinformationen im internet als
großes gesellschaftliches problem an
um dieses problem grundsätzlich zu
wissen heißt hier aber noch nicht
gezielte desinformation im konkreten
fall auch als solche zu erkennen oder
dagegen immun zu sein
stefan mappus hat sich damit befasst
welche rolle das bei der bundestagswahl
spielen könnte die landtagswahl in
sachsen-anhalt lief noch da ging es
schon los in sozialen netzwerken zweifel
nutzer das wahlergebnis an
auch in einschlägigen telegramm gruppen
wurde ohne beweise wahlbetrug behauptet
der vorwurf ist ein abklatsch dessen was
nach der präsidentschaftswahl in den usa
von trump anhängern verbreitet wurde
und es ist ein hinweis darauf wie auch
die kommende bundestagswahl ziel von des
informationskampagnen werden könnte also
die deutsche bundestagswahl steht im
fadenkreuz verschiedener desinformations
akteure sowohl inländische gruppen
rechter gruppen afg nahe gruppen als
auch ausländische regierungen wie vor
allem der russischen regierung die mit
staatlichen medien schon lange eine
desinformationskampagne gegen
deutschland fährt die bundesregierung
hat auch wegen solcher akteure die ag
hybride bedrohungen gegründet geleitet
wird sie vom innenministerium was die ag
bislang erreicht hat das will man uns
wieder vor der kamera noch schriftlich
mitteilen
die regierung und die zuständige behörde
das bsi vertrauen darauf dass die großen
sozialen netzwerke allen voran facebook
gegen falschinformationen und
manipulations kampagnen vorgehen werden
für die bundestagswahl ganz konkret gibt
es ein ich nenne es mal ein rotes
telefon zwischen dem bsc und facebook
zwischen den zwei lagezentren das
sollten wir feststellen dass es eine
desinformationskampagne gibt die auf die
bundestagswahl ab zielt auf facebook
werden wir diese entfernen wir werden
dann unmittelbar dass bse informieren
facebook und co löschen und sperren
schon seit längerem vermehrt viele
verschwörungs ideologen und extremisten
sind auf alternative plattformen
ausgewichen allen voran
auf telegramm der messenger dienst hat
seinen sitz offiziell in dubai und ist
für den deutschen staat kaum greifbar
auch eine zweite gefahr bereitet den
sicherheitsbehörden kopfzerbrechen so
genannte hack and lee kooperationen
abgeordnete und kandidierende sind
häufig das ziel von hacker-angriffen die
dabei erbeuteten daten können eingriffe
veröffentlichen um den wahlkampf zu
beeinflussen
also ich habe schon erlebt dass leute
versucht haben sich in meine
it-infrastruktur einzuwählen wir haben
das im umfeld auch beobachtet dass wir
kollegen opfer von phishing angriffen
geworden sind wir haben gesehen dass
kollegen aus dem bundestag ganz gezielt
auch ausgeforscht worden sind um
handynummern herauszufinden
dagegen helfen sollen laut regierung
schulungen und informationsbroschüren
ob das reicht wird sich im september bei
der wahl zum nächsten bundestag zeigen
und jetzt nochmal heinz mit anderen
leitungen vor gut zwei wochen waren drei
chinesische raumfahrer am kernmodul der
im bau befindlichen chinesischen
weltraumstation angekommen
und nun haben zwei von ihnen einen
ersten außenbordeinsatz erfolgreich
absolviert während ihrer siebenstündige
mission richteten sie eine panorama
kamera ein und nahmen arbeiten am
roboterarm vor die raumstation tiangong
zu deutsch himmelspalast soll bis ende
2022 fertiggestellt werden und aus drei
modulen bestehen erstmals seit 13 jahren
haben sich die deutschen basketballer
wieder für olympia qualifiziert das team
von bundestrainer henrik rödl gewannen
im kroatischen split das finale des
qualifikationsturniers gegen brasilien
und sicherte sich damit das ticket für
tokio in der formel 1 heute der nächste
triumph für max verstappen er gewann den
großen preis von österreich in spielberg
der dritte sieg in folge für den
niederländer
max deppen führt nach dem start von der
noris im orangefarbenen mclaren die
mercedes piloten wieder keine gegner für
den niederländern us hamilton erkämpft
sich zunächst rang zwei dann baut der
linke hinterreifen massiv ab sowohl
fotos als auch der mclaren-pilot
überholen ihn bekommen aber keinen
kontakt zur spitze sebastian vettels
wochenende bedeutungslos nach strafe und
startplatz elf räumt kimi räikkönens
alfa romeo den deutschen von der strecke
er wird nur 17 verstappen siegt vor
bottas und norris seien erneute erfolg
beschert ihm jetzt schon 30 punkte
vorsprung in der wm vor lewis hamilton
[Applaus]
frauen haben ein deutlich höheres risiko
an einem herzinfarkt zu sterben als
männer
warum weil sie andere symptome zeigen
das medizinische personal ist aber
darauf geschult die männlichen symptome
zu erkennen
bei weiblichen patienten wird deshalb
ein infarkt häufiger nicht erkannt so
war das natürlich nicht gemeint als
frauen die hälfte des himmels forderten
tatsächlich hat das aber system auch
viele medikamente sind vor allem an
männlichen probanden entwickelt worden
dass frauen eine andere dosierung oder
zusammensetzung bräuchten
damit hat sich die pharma branche
bislang wenig befasst
aber es geht nicht nur um medizinisches
frauen haben auch ein höheres risiko bei
einem autounfall zu sterben
und nein nicht weil sie schlechter auto
fahren würden
all das beschreibt ein buch mit dem
bezeichnenden titel das patriarchat der
dinge dort ferber über normen für die
die hälfte der bevölkerung eine
abweichung ist eine öffentliche toilette
mitten in köln
für männer ist das original gratis
frauen müssen zahlen und oft erwarten
ein beispiel für die männlich normierte
welt sagt rebbe händler
das bedeutet dass nicht nur für frauen
auch für viele andere personen die welt
so gestaltet ist dass sie uns nicht
passt dass das problem auch als solches
erkannt wird ist
schritt nummer 1 und eben nicht als
pipifax abgetan wird wie im fall der
öffentlichen toiletten die männlich
normierte welt wird gefahren für frau
beim crashtest wird ein männlicher
standard dummy eingesetzt ein meter 77
groß 80 kilo schwer
der frauen dummy entspricht einer
zwölfjährigen und wird nur auf dem
beifahrersitz getestet die gefahr für
frauen bei einem unfall schwer verletzt
zu werden
mit 50 prozent höher als bei männern ein
sehr großer bereich ist noch und
erforscht was man braucht es belastbare
daten um überhaupt sagen zu können
dieses fahrzeug ist für frauen für
kleine für alte für dicke menschen nicht
gemacht nicht getestet den sogenannten
gender data gap gibt es überall in büros
ist die standard temperatur auf den mann
ausgerichtet frauen ist es meist zu kalt
beim einkaufen sind die obersten regale
für frauen oft zu hoch und anwalts roben
sollen majestätisch wirken aber die
vorschriften für falten und besatz sind
genau vermeintliche richter als ich als
junge anwältin angefangen habe und eine
klassische robe über geworfen habe ich
bin ein bisschen drin versunken und habe
mich eben genau so gefühlt obwohl ich
doch eigentlich jetzt die sache meines
mandanten vertreten wollte und total
souverän auftreten wollte kuba hat schon
vor einigen jahren eine robe entworfen
die frauen passt aber noch immer sind
die rechtsvorschriften nicht in allen
bundesländern so dass diese robe auch
den normen entspricht patriarchat der
dinge hat rebecca endler die männlich
normierte welt getauft sie will
passenderes was wir brauchen es ein ganz
anderes bewusstsein für design und
gestaltung wir müssen uns klarmachen
dass die welt von menschen entworfen
wurden die
die eigenen vorurteile und ihre eigenen
ideen auch was was rollen klischees und
so weiter betrifft mit in das design
eingebunden haben noch eine
zukunftsvision
sie zeigen sie an der zürcher hochschule
für angewandte wissenschaften die stadt
geplant von und für frauen mit
ampelphasen die auch kleinkinder
schaffen
und natürlich mit ausreichend toiletten
von solchen visionen für eine mutmaßlich
noch ferne zukunft kommen wir zum
ausblick auf die nächste woche
welche ereignisse da anstehen hat die an
weiter zusammengestellt
[Musik]
am dienstag werden in cannes die
filmfestspiele eröffnet nachdem corona
bedingten ausfall im letzten jahr soll
dieses jahr wieder alles erstrahlen
natürlich corona konform auch um der
welt mit einem großen kultur event zu
zeigen frankreich hat kurth im griff in
italien beginnt am donnerstag die
gerichtliche aufarbeitung des seilbahn
unglücks von stresa am lago maggiore
14 menschen kamen bei dem absturz am
pfingstsonntag ums leben das zugseil der
bahn war gerissen und die notbremse
außer betrieb gesetzt mit vorsatz so die
ermittler um trotz störungen den betrieb
aufrecht zu erhalten
am samstag wird in new york der uno
sicherheitsrat entscheiden ob der letzte
offene grenzübergängen in die syrische
region ist weiter offen gehalten wird
für hilfskonvois aus der türkei weil die
lieferungen nicht nur die 2,6 millionen
flüchtlinge dort am leben halten sondern
auch die rebellen der opposition will
syriens machthaber assad das verhindern
und sein verbündeter russland könnte mit
seinem veto dafür sorgen
[Musik]
am sonntag wird im wembley stadion in
london das em finale angepfiffen doch
wie viele zuschauer werden auf den
rängen sitzen rund 40.000 waren es beim
deutschlandspiel angesichts cupid in der
delta variante hat das für scharfe
kritik gesorgt dennoch für sonntag plant
die uefa mit 60.000 zuschauern
[Musik]
und jetzt noch die wetteraussichten für
morgen im norden und der mitte auf
bewölkt und einige teils kräftige
schauer und gewitter im süden länger
freundlich und weitgehend trocken
höchstwerte 20 bis 26 grad
die weiteren aussichten am dienstag im
osten sonnig bei bis zu 32 grad im
westen kühler und neue kräftige gewitter
auch dann auch unbeständig bei 20 bis 27
grad
das was man uns weiter geht's gleich mit
inspector barnaby der ermittelt heute
auf einem weingut nach einem tödlichen
tropfen sozusagen und um 0.30 gibt es
dann die nächste heute express uns
morgen danach wieder sehen will
[Musik]